tenue de la réunion la
nouvelle-calédonie lions de saint martin
moi je viens de sa bien l'île de la
réunion de toute la france
métropolitaine et d'outre-mer plus de
150 représentants 2 pl ont été reçus
dans l'hémicycle du département
localement ce statut juridique et le
cadre d'intervention de 35 sociétés qui
agissent dans le cadre de la politique
publique
le président de la nordev est ici le
président de la fédération locale
la mission elle évolue bien sûr et elle
va continuer la preuve c'est que l'année
dernière la réunion s'est permis
d'inventer l'aide à la personne dans la
création donc des réelles et nous avons
réussi par ce biais a proposé à la
métropole que la loi prenne en
considération cette ce nouvel secteurs
d'activité l'ouverture par le président
du département de cette séance de
travail a été marquée par l'hommage à
marc andré hoarau ancien président d
opel de l'océan indien décédé récemment
[Musique]
thomas choix de travail rigaud plein de
conviction et donc vous le rendre cet
hommage en présence
ces institutions font l'histoire du
développement de notre territoire et
cela depuis des années 60 et l'idée
c'est d'aller beaucoup plus vite parce
que moi je vous le dis très sincèrement
parfois nos administrations sont
renfermés dans de longues procédures qui
empêche d'aller trop de bad trois
revirements et nous nous avons des
actions menées en matière
d'investissements en matière de
réhabilitation des logements insalubres
et bien il n'y a rien de mieux que les
appels voix le faire c'est pour cela que
nous sommes heureux d'accueillir cette
fédération pense que au delà de la
réunion nous pouvons dialoguer échanger
avec les appels venant d'autres horizons
d'autres collectivités d'outre-mer et ça
nous permet de nous enrichir de nos
expériences
toute la semaine les congressistes ont
visité les nombreux cm et spl de l'île
afin d'échanger sur les différentes
expériences pour mieux appréhender les
enjeux de demain
[Musique]